hey everyone it's sarah register
nurserian.com and in this video i'm
going to talk about trusocine so let's
get started tristo sign is a specific
type of muscle spasm that occurs in the
hand and wrist due to neuromuscular
irritability which tends to be a
definitive sign of low calcium in the
blood hypocalcemia
it can also occur whenever a patient has
a low magnesium level in the blood now
how do we assess for a true cosine well
you're looking for either a positive or
a negative sign positive meaning the
patient has it negative meaning they do
not so in order to do this you need a
manual blood pressure cuff along with
being aware of the patient's latest
blood pressure reading specifically you
want to be aware of that systolic number
of the blood pressure reading which is
the top number next you want to place
the blood pressure cuff on the arm and
inflate this cuff to a pressure greater
than the patient's systolic number and
hold it there for about three minutes
now while you are holding it there you
want to look at that arm that has a
blood pressure cuff on it specifically
that hand and wrist and you want to
monitor the reaction that is occurring
on that side if it is positive the hand
will draw in toward the body and flexion
will occur at the wrist thumb and mcp
joints but the fingers will remain
extended and if nothing occurs during
this that means that it is a negative
truso sign so why does this occur well
whenever we place a cuff on a patient's
arm and we inflate it above their
systolic blood pressure we're occluding
the brachial artery and the brachial
artery gives blood flow to the
structures down here like your forearm
your wrist and your hands well whenever
a patient has a low calcium level their
nerves and muscles are already irritable
and too excited so whenever we impede
that blood flow hence cause ischemia
it's going to cause these structures
down here to spasm okay so that wraps up
this review over trusosign and if you'd
like to watch more review lectures you
can access the link in the youtube
description below